[музика]
друзі привіт але ще боттом до нашої
супер драйвові рух анька у нас сьогодні
в гостях дзеркал гей тренер дієтолог не на
радіо вс до олександр барабашку від нашого
риб а ну раз пачино це друзі проїду
цієї і давайте танцювати і весь раз
ручка води на 1 2 3 4 1 2 0
[музика]
ручка
сторони ламайте
. одна комбінація наша ворона
а
хоча б розумієш вийде крок і баньці
курчат
[музика]
а
і ось
і
іран
анальний
там і
орально ліжко ще раз і
а танці тягнути його
танці
та ручка ціну
одна комбінація
[музика]
сірий
адже спочиваємо
[музика]
давай давай
і 2
[музика]
і
а
[музика]
mute
одна комбінація наша
а
і
та пінгувати дається вже промо нам дзвінок
я вам дуже взяти на друзі ви дуже
route de aqua вам круто дозу зустріч
[музика]